[Musique]
la congélation
voilà une excellente façon de préserver
des aliments et d'éviter le gaspillage
anne-marie des biens à qui l'on doit cet
ouvrage de référence sur la conservation
nous offre ses précieux conseils pour
mieux combler commençons par les fruits
est ce que tous les fruits ce qu'on gère
oui toutes les frises de congères mais
il y en a certains qui ont besoin des
petites attentions particulières
certains fruits comme les bananes pommes
les avocats ont tendance à brûler
rapidement l'expérience qu'on a fait ici
c'est vraiment d'ajouter des acides pour
empêcher le brunissement des fruits
bernardin créer un produit on au cabinet
l'acide citrique du jus de citron avec
de l'acide ascorbique et à vitamines dit
c'est donc tout à fait sécuritaire
c'est sous forme de poudre donc ce
produit là ici la sas corbic et la
vitamine c est encore plus efficace pour
éviter le brunissement voilà le résultat
ici même ça viendra c'est bon quand même
c'est juste un changement d'apparence
donc rien à voir avec le goût ya un
avantage à congeler les fruits ce qu'on
conserve plus de vitamines ça détruit
paul il termine la congélation
donc c'est une des techniques de
conservation qui garde de la mieux
l'intégrité en fait de l'ennemi pour les
petits fruits
anne marie propose une congélation en
deux étapes
il est allé sur un taux de biscuits
salle accélère la vitesse de congélation
et plus vite on congèle plus les
cristaux de glace qui vont se former à
l'intérieur on voit une petit seul écrit
retour de gasquet ce qui peut briser les
cellules donc peut briser la texture qui
altèrent les aliments dans ce qu'on veut
savoir les plus petits cristaux possible
ils vont avoir de meilleurs textes à la
décongélation
ça va empêcher qui s'agglutinent c'est
pendant les congés citoyens peu la
différence entre les deux c'est une
fausse idée congelé à la décongélation
de moins liquide donc les framboises qui
sont des concombres et des yeux l'homme
au moins de liquide que celle qu'ont
avis tout ensemble
autre technique l'ajout de sucre
le but d'ajouter du sucre et c'est
d'avoir un effet cryoprotecteurs donc un
cryoprotecteurs c'est le nom qu'on nomme
molécules qui vont protéger quelque
chose au froid donc rio ça veut dire
froid donc ce qu'on peut faire c'est
protéger la phrase en l'enrobant de
sucre donc le suc va agir comme un genre
de petit cocon autour de france qui va
ralentir les dommages décrypte gars qui
pourrait affecter sa texture est ici on
a l'exemple de pâtes sucre du tout à la
fois totalement décongeler les phrases
avec le sucre vont avoir une meilleure
textures ont pu se tenir
donc si on veut faire par exemple une
tarte aux fraises ou des coupures de
presse avec des morceaux mais on est
mieux de prendre des fraises congelé
dans le sud des fraises de congeler
nature est ce que tous les légumes
peuvent être congelés est ce qu'on doit
toujours blanchir et oui en fait
pratiquement tous les légumes folie
blancheur il ya quelques exceptions
comme les pommes de pas les courges et
légumes racines qui sont très denses et
légumes là en fait pour aller cueillir
avant décongeler donc cela blanchiment
ça sera pas suffisant mais tous les
autres légumes et bénéficier à être
blanchi
et si vous les avez juste coupé levé
j'ai mis dans le contenant en
blanchissant à partir de 60 degrés
celsius les enzymes sont détruits hélas
ce moment là les failles premier or
votre conserver plus longtemps qu'en
plus ils envoient une meilleure textures
pour les fines herbes
voici le truc pour bien et congelés le
basilic
on ne l'a mise à conserver passer une
des seules fermes qui n'aiment pas être
réfrigérés le congelé dans l'huile comme
ça lui il va protéger les feuilles en
fait de basilic puis ça va nous faire
aussi une huile déjà rebaptisé donc si
vous voulez vous faire des sauces tomate
à la maison pendant l'hiver il suffit de
seulement prendre un cube de le mélanger
avec de l'ail pays via la sauce tomate
classement ne vous avez une belle
recette déjà prête pour la prochaine
expérience crevettes et poulets sont
congelés de trois façons différentes
dans un sac de congélation dans un plat
est ici sans emballage le pire scénario
c'est celui là ici on ne fait congeler
nos aliments directement à l'air libre
puis vous voyez ici le poulain audrey
qui cuit mais y ai cru donc c'est les
brûlures de congélation et c'est
vraiment une déshydratation de l'aliment
ça fait en sorte que la viande à de
l'arc 8 pc parce que habilement été
congés dans un un contenant trop grand
trop dans l'air ambiant donc pas assez
étanche on vous et s'aérer sur l'aliment
laquelle le goût d'un bip affectés mais
c'est vraiment plus la texture donc on
va faire cuire les aliments secs un peu
plus coriace
cette partie là justement parce que
c'est déshydraté donc c'est un défaut
qui est pas très plaisant embauches qui
est pas grave l'important vraiment idéal
mandat ballet sous vide mais souvent
n'est pas équipée pour faire du souvenir
donc une des techniques c'est de prendre
des sacs comme seul ne peut prendre des
vacances et les congrès tu les as et
même ces cinq clubs sont des sacs de
congélation donc c'est conçu pour le
congélateur son lavabo la vaisselle donc
on peut les réutiliser aussi parce
qu'ils sont plus épais versus les sacs
normes prochaine catégories de produits
des types on peut tout les congés
n'importe quel produit laitier la seule
chose qui va reverser ce fait la texture
qui se brise avec l'adq la congélation
ans thierry plus il ya d'eau dans notre
produit laitier plus il y aura de
cristaux de glace et plus on va voir des
milliers des pays qui vont briser notre
produit en mairie conseils de rappeler
certains fromages avant de les congeler
pour une fois on va avoir des plus
petits morceaux de fromage ces petits
morceaux là mon congé plus rapidement
que si on les avait laissés en gros
blocs d eux des cocos on congères ou pas
on peut les congeler les oeufs entiers
donc dans ce sens on enlève la coquille
et on garde l'oeuf et le blanc le jaune
d'oeuf sauf que sam est important
d'ajouter un cryoprotecteurs en faut
absolument mettre soi du sel ou du sucre
pour protéger le jaune d'oeuf et qui
sortent une fois décongelés avec une
bonne texture donc avec une texture
équipe aux granules c'est vraiment ça le
problème des jaunes d'oeuf d'encoder
blanc d'oeuf tel quel après un certain
ton congélateur les animaux peuvent
perdre leur saveur et parfois leur
valeur nutritive
mais c'est sans risque pour la santé
référez vous aux documents terme au
guide du mapaq et surtout assurez vous
que votre congélateur soit au moins à
-18 à cette température-là ont garanti
qui a aucun micro gagner ce qui pousse
non pas de leurs portes d'acquérir tout
ça dorment sont pas morts sont juste
endormi donc idéalement c'est au moins -
18 oui on pourrait se rendre jusqu'à -24
donc si on passe de moins de 18 ans - 24
notre poulet congelé ou de te garder
doses - ce concert 24 mois donc on
double la durée de vie en congelant plus
froids un peu
[Musique]